quelles sont vos revendications vous
alors chad banane ou revendication pour
revendique déjà contre la réforme du bac
c'est quoi alors le bac 2021 c'est ce
passé le bac 2021 c'est une nouvelle
réforme qui a été mise en place l'année
dernière pour les 2003 ouais les seconds
aujourd'hui sa voix est en fait ça
consiste à supprimer complètement les
filières et que les élèves en 1re
choisissent à trois matières dans un
tronc commun et trois matières
spécialisés et nous ce qu'on n'aime pas
dans cette réforme c'est plus que en
fait les 90% des élèves ne sont sont ne
savent pas du tout ce qu'ils vont faire
plus tard est salée mais dans un flou
total parce que les spécialités sont
complètement fous rouge
qu'est-ce qu'elle ne comprend rien du
tout qu'est-ce qui vous disent vos
parents quand ils vous voient aller
manifester ils vous disent quoi moi mes
parents des bus était pour sauf que
quand ils ont canton quand je me suis
fait exclure du quoi c'était moins
content parce que du coup avec un
parcours sud
bah ouais voilà j'arrête d'y discuter
parentois bah moi mes parents quand j'ai
faim j'ai pas fait de tentative de
blocus
mais j'ai porté une pancarte ma
condamnation devant ici j'étais viré
pour ça vous avez porté une page au cap
mâcon démission il a été viré oui c'est
vos parents ils vont déchirer au perdant
comme avant attends un mauvais jeu donc
ils vous disent quoi vous dites vous ils
vous disent de vous calmer ce qu'ils ont
peur de tous ces mouvements qui se passe
actuellement et non aux parents non bah
ça dépend il faut quoi et c'est quoi tes
parents dans la vie ils ont mon père il
est chef cuisinier ma mère est
auxiliaire de vie d'accord et à des
métiers facile que c'est sympa bien sûr
et toi c'est vrai ça me paraîtrait ma
musique et ma mère elle est prof
d'histoire remplaçante d'accord très
bien oui oui mais je me pose la question
à savoir que c'était ma l'un d'eux vous
greffer sur la vraie misère des gens sur
le vrai malheur des gens n'ont pas assez
de fric pour finir le mois
évidemment vous rajouter de la mer d'un
moyen et vidéo les jeux pan même si je
comprends vos revendications va les
pauvres
déjà déjà que les jeunes tu aimais pas
du bas modération triste pour des gens
nous avons calculé gilet jaune
au contraire moi je suis désolé c'est
pas parce que les ont laissé savoir
qu'on s'attend à tous notre quart avant
d'y renoncer car il ya tout dans les
jeunes qui vont pas aller dans ces cas
là ça va me motiver mais comment adele a
débloqué si l'ampleur jusqu'à rien dans
la mer en ce moment je travaille à deux
secondes les chéri matthew pouvait pas
dire on a tous un truc a revendiqué il
ya des gens on peut on va on va pas se
mentir
mais si on est des privilégiés on va pas
dire on va passer au dessus des caraïbes
bernard là je pense que la réforme du
bac n'a rien à faire avec déjà une wii
en train de crever de faim ces deux
choses différentes mais monsieur en fait
on est bien difficile où les gens
s'approchent à toi tu sois content alors
allez-y c'est notre fête on est venu ici
on a été invités gentiment ici bah oui
revendiqué lé le mécontentement des
demis et en français ici oui parce qu'en
fait on trouve que parcours sup et le
nouveau bac philo presque complètement
les élèves et ça l'est dans une merde
total je suis désolé de le dire un pour
le diriger et nord et leur parcours
professionnel
est ce que je sais c'est que si on
essayait de revendiquer publiquement
mais elle mais comptant les sous sont
pâles greffer aussi les jaunes
elle pense aussi à leur allié russe
vigilants sur ce salon verra pas c'est
pas parce qu'on a bloqué lundi qu'on
soutient forcément léger les jeunes n'en
avait fait des blocus
je vais te dire et le dernier blocus est
offerte contre l'émission morandini
à